mama mia here we go again my my
something something something friend
mama Mia
dancing queen dancing queen shut the
fuck up the best proof I'm not I did not
hurt uh Papa songs good sure got most of
that wrong alright so if you missed it
before this is uh honest thoughts on
movies that we review is the nostalgia
critic um which by the way we mentioned
the last one but if there's any movies
we've reviewed before and the N see that
you want to know we're honest thoughts
about her just talked about leave in the
comments below we're definitely looking
for uh what you guys want to hear about
um and this is Mamma Mia this is a film
that I definitely didn't like and I
thought was awful but by God out of all
the films we've reviewed you have said
this is your number two most hated angry
film I don't even know if it would make
my top ten but that's fascinating so I'm
just gonna let you have the floor on
this one
I uh I mean number one we both can agree
is still Garbage Pail Kids yeah that's
still number one that's the worst movie
ever reviewed ever saw at absolute worst
but yeah it it's close actually it's
very close I am I don't know what it is
because I I said that I I said on my
public Facebook that this may be one of
the ones that like broke me and I and I
said I know a lot of you are gonna be
like really that one like it could have
been anything like that's the one that
broke you with I can't explain it I
don't know why but it's almost like this
movie was like literally tailor-made
just to annoy me and me only like you
literally like raba Mia yeah somebody
out there was we were like hey this is
guy named Rob Walker let's create the
one thing in the universe that could
annoy him most well put everything he
hates into 1vl like I that's what it was
I what what was it
that annoyed you proud you want to bring
the movie out where didn't know where
did the movie touch up I mean I guess
the I guess you're so filled with
emotion about it let me try I'll try to
say the stuff that annoyed me and I'll
have you go off of that okay yeah we
start um for me
uh people have said the stage show is
better
I just watching this movie I can't
imagine anything good coming out of this
setup and I don't hey table I can i can
assume me to look acting in the stage
show was better in the singing because
yes she's frozen in the Meryl Streep
trying to sing that that literally was
like a cat and a dog wrestling or just
oh that there's something I think for me
cuz I had to sit through and this isn't
even like the worst or anything but I
had to sit through the Sex in the City
movie to review it years ago
see I didn't see that so maybe that
would be worse I don't know it's by no
means worse uh in fact honestly having
not seen the show uh in the grand scheme
of things in the Sexson City movie is
not like the worst most god-awful movie
it wasn't like super cringe-worthy but
I'm watching this movie and it's like oh
it's a chick flick it's a chick flick
and that was always the excuse people
had and I just remember thinking myself
there's if that's working with chick
flicks deserve better
ya know the way better there's the sense
that you know you can have something
focus much more out of female the point
of view and there are just gonna be
different points of views you know based
on gender it's not lives there's three
sorts of chick flicks there's chick
flicks are legitimately good maybe can
appeal to guys as well there's your
fantasy style chick flicks where it's
bunch of girls getting together watch
movie and it's an over-the-top
ridiculous fantasy and like I can't
fault women for that I mean Christ look
at what we watch his guys like it's
ridiculous yeah we have frickin fucking
commando yeah it's awesome but I'm like
it makes no sense so it's do so
you know we know this so anyway and then
there's the the chick flicks that are
just insulting to the entire female
gender and that was this
I think there's yeah there's an it
doesn't what else has because it's a
chick flick because it's bad as a movie
it's bad as a chick flick it's bad as a
musical it's pretty much bad as
everything except for the cinematography
which was decent sounds like I'm talking
like fifty Shades of Grey yeah no no the
acting everything in this in Mamma Mia
is is bad you know Fifty Shades it's
like okay they're trying on the
directing to try on it but I did think a
lot of Fifty Shades of Grey watching or
vice versa I thought of Mamma Mia
watching Fifty Shades I'm like I can
tell this is a good director just stuck
with a bad movie because this director
went on to do Iron Lady which is a far
superior law and the movie comes off
like that like fifty Shades of Grey it
came off as somebody's like I got handed
shit okay well I'm gonna at least make
this as pretty looking as hell so I'll
get another job and then I'll do a
better movie hope yeah like that this is
my just my foot in the door but there
may be part of the reason why the movie
annoyed me is much even less so than
fifty shades of gray light or even more
some Fifty Shades of Grey I felt like
there was no real effort to try to put
something together that made sense like
Fifty Shades of Grey
I could see at least where they had this
shitty book and we're trying somehow to
make something good out of it and failed
miserably but I could see where maybe
but this just was like autopilot it's
like here's some great cinematography
and that's it everything else was like
it was like paint by numbers or just
like here's this song here's that song
here's the scene here's that scene Oh
thought put into it no rhyme or reason
just here's some shit like I think
there's a sense of you know like it what
we were talking about like with commando
and stuff like that like we'll watch it
it will acknowledge it shit I will
transfer the first transformers love it
it's stupid fucking shit you know it is
so dumb but at the same time I think
even for shit there should be a little
bit more effort put in there should be
something new so this would have been
something entertaining this at least
could have been a so
bad it's good hilariously over-the-top
job it's not even that like I can't even
I can't even argue like you know you you
end up watching a chick flick you know
with your girlfriend or wife or whatever
or something's on TV and you're just
like well this looks funny at least it's
not even like funny like haha but this
is just kind of dumb it's just painful
there is no plot none like from the very
beginning it is the most ridiculous
thing it's like I'm gonna write to my
three fathers and a few days before my
wedding few days before my one of the
hell you fucking weirdo what it's not
even like a good haha that's so stupid
it's funny plant is this stupid yeah no
they're not treating it like oh these
people just don't know any better or no
I hate it when chick flicks do that like
they do the Julia Roberts and kinda used
to be Sandra Bullock thing where it's
like oh she's acting like a fucking
psycho but Oh doesn't know any better
chicks
we're emotional huh that's it that is
the entire movie it's literally like
Meryl Streep's daughter and her friends
are guys are just the guys aren't
wah-wah and then em day and then Meryl
Streep and her two friends are yeah and
like Meryl you want the most obnoxious
Meryl Streep performance you will ever
see in your life this movie it's her
entire performances ah I'm shouting I'm
some sort of aging hippie come on girls
let's do it breasts sisters like he had
to everything on the down tempo
everything in its exactly like this
literally is if you took Gilbert Godfrey
cut off his balls and gave him ovaries
this is what he would sound like that is
Meryl Streep very woman in this film um
so there's no plot there's and this is
what we were talking about because I in
the middle of this movie I turned you
and I was just like you know done I'm
sorry but this is this is what you're
gonna hate most about the filming like
what I'm like Moulin Rouge the film that
you hate I have Moulin Rouge to mises
and but he can't stand it um
Moulin Rouge which you hate had a better
idea of how to incorporate these very
disparate songs into a story not a great
story but
a story they tied into a narrative a
narrative that made some semblance of
sense you can argue it's a cliched over
the top romantic date but it was a
coherent narrative then we had a
coherent narrative beginning to end I'm
like this is just random some idiot just
grab random ABBA songs is like let's
write a plot around this and like that
the plot just doesn't make any sense my
two favorites the ones where I really am
like what the fuck is going on here is
the one where the the side character one
of the sisters uh this black guy comes
out he's like hey can we date and he
sings a song about it's like she's a
side character we don't know who this
guy is like image of the baby - then
when the movie is clearly you imagine
any sort of chick flick where there's
just a side character that gets 15
minutes of screen time randomly for a
plethora that goes nowhere absolutely
nowhere and like there was a whole song
and dance number about this and I'm like
he never comes back what the fuck does
this have to do with anything I
literally I was like The Truman Show
it's like what are you talking about
what does this have to do with anything
it was like they're like some random ad
inserted into Ellen what the fuck is
this and then the other is one the old
lady and the other sister I guess at the
end like looks at one of the possible
fathers and it's just like I think it
was scars huh yeah no it's like horse
cards oh I like came out of Thor - with
more dignity than he did in this move
and I think he was running around half
naked through that film and she's just
suddenly like you know hey you want to
date me and it's like movies over
everything that can be everything it's
overnight I mean another song with this
woman who has no character not a no way
skarsgård who is is the barest amount of
character and and it's a that's funny
because she's all that she wants to date
him and there's another song is so close
to being done and loving throwing this
song like you fucking shitting me there
is no barista time because the songs
have nothing to do with anything
it whitter it's almost like a tummy was
so film it is so just makes no sense
like the decision-making that went on
too
with this musical yeah made no sense and
the funny thing is I I was talking to
Brad about it cuz Brad's like oh he's
like Mamma Mia oh good god and I mean no
again yeah and he's like yeah no I
haven't seen that movie and I was
telling him I'm like I don't even hate
ah but he's like that's actually why I
don't want to see it because I'm
legitimately like Abba and I get the
feeling if I watch this movie I'm gonna
hate them forever and I laugh cuz it's
like Brad that's what happened to me I
oughta to me is one of those groups that
they exist I don't like I'm indifferent
to it I don't hate them catchy so I
don't love them there was nothing
nothing I was into but I was like that's
fine the existing people like I'm I
don't I don't care
doesn't bother me I'll tell you this
going in completely different to ABBA
coming out of this movie I will never be
able to listen to an Abba sauce without
getting violently ill without either
wanting to stab somebody in the eyes or
just vomit profusely all over the place
like that is how freakin annoying and I
think that's I think that's the key it's
that this movie was not just bad because
we've review a lot of bad news it was
obnoxiously in-your-face annoying every
single scene was singing makes no sense
ha Meryl Streep add and imagine Brosnan
with his rear I kid and my voice is
going oh oh and that you're not yet it's
like nothing at the only song I could
think of that you like was sounding okay
was the I think don't go chasing your
emotions like the what were they do the
Hitler Mario jump ooh but her the fuck
that was but the actual like a company
in that there like that sound okay all
the others yet it's just they all are so
annoyingly obnoxious and they're trying
so hard like not to sound good you know
it all sounds like karaoke done by and
mother I heard a story I don't know if
this is true but some friend told me
that apparently Meryl Streep was in
interviews around what Mamma Mia came on
just like I don't understand what the
big deal is you know you just you just
sing you just do it you don't need that
here
they turn the camera on you sing him and
that's it and I'm like well that showed
like because it literally sounds like
somebody who doesn't know how to sing
has no talent you know to sing without
any training whatsoever was just shoved
up Cameron said here belt this tune out
I hear at some point she like she
realized she when she saw the waves he's
like oh I'm bad and got lessons for into
the water and into the woods is you're
like redemptive swan song and hear that
Heidi but I'm still singing like that
see that but she has that nice she got
nominated it all was one of the Oscar
jokes I'm just like well it's Meryl
streak as we got nominator nobody's
Medill but her performance it into the
woods you know that that looked like
frickin Citizen Kane like competitive
shit lease had a few slow songs where
she pulled it off to fine
you know it feels you know it is an
oscar-worthy know it's my I say that
usually as a joke that's like no what
you have to got nominated but um but no
it was totally fine
and then this just nobody sounds good
everyone sounds awful and if that story
is true then shame on her a you know
what I would say shame on her but
actually just being caught on camera for
all to see singing that badly better
shame it's not everyone says she has
already been thoroughly punished because
that footage exists I can't go be
deleted I will say I don't know
if that story is true either because I
try to find an interview because
somebody told me you someone who like
that'd be great for the review and I
couldn't find it
so that doesn't mean it's not out there
I'm saying we literally don't know if it
I'll tell you this though the fact that
she went on camera and didn't after
looking at the dailies go I quit get me
out of this contract I will pay you
whatever not to me like find someone
else who can sing or find somebody to
double me that is hubris that is some
serious arrogance there is like it is so
bad yeah there is a hell like oddest
posters for like the Oscar picks or
whatever one was very into the would no
no no well do what your parents see when
they see movie posters and the into the
woods one was I like Meryl Streep but
air
singing you know but likes it it turned
out okay and into the woods but he
definitely got lessons after that
because that was the noise we heard I'm
surprised she I'm surprised she
literally had the chutzpah to you know
actually try it again but I'll give her
credit it was much better and into the
woods
yeah so it's she sounds like you're
strangling a cat like Pierce Rosen
sounds like you just shot a dog and he's
just dying slowly it is the most
horrible pin of like I I closed my eyes
I just saw this dog just on the girl I'm
like I can't do this this is cruel um it
was I think for me like with the cuz
like I said I'm one of those people
where I totally agree with you about
like the three kind of different kinds
of chick flicks and stuff cuz there are
something like I think like we're
talking to Tamra and Tamra's everything
you know and we're talking about
Princess Diaries in the first one she's
like I love the first one I can't help
but I just love it and it's like even
though I don't like it like I get it
that there commando you know like that
we know this is stupid but it's harmless
princess and Irish's Schindler's List
yeah ya know there's something to
there's there's not this insulting
element of you're a statistic you're a
mathematic equation where if we do this
because we see other successful things
do this we'll do that as well you know
that's or the twilit is it is the old
woman equivalent of those stupid Vegas
movies where it's like Morgan Freeman
and uh who the hell's is it I know I
know you're talking about where it's
like here's four old actors and they're
going to Vegas to have some fun and it's
funny cuz they're all but you know like
you know early it's just like it's like
the female alone of one of those I'm
like this is just insulting to old
actors usually they have much more
dignity than to be in a movie like
here's the thing - honestly I mean
you're talking about like this is for
you know older or middle-aged women and
stuff like that it's Kali don't they
deserve better
it's like yeah we can give them their
beginning there's a bunch of dudes with
their bare chest running around with hot
chiseled physique but go watch a porno
this isn't this porn sand porn movies
have better plots than this well there's
just gotta be like I said I'm not a
chick flick on TV tonight ray before had
a plot compared to this there at least
what is a plot not a good puppet there's
no plot to this movie and then was the
problem it was just song after song
after song with no rhyme or reason no
real plot it's just like we need an
excuse for a song and they never ended
it just was one constant song like when
we would get three lines of dialogue and
they would launch into another song and
I literally just started like punching
my ears like fer sure and I was like
Doug make it stop it does get really in
Suffern oh I always said by the end just
when they kept four it's like we're
always so close to the end he's like
what you know wait let's not get married
they'll sing a song about that wait how
about these two get married sing a song
about that here's their asset that was
saying a song I was my favorite movie is
over we're still guessing a song about
these other two that like fucking
whatever now ours a couple like that
that was my favorite cuz even gotten
married by a priest I like I laugh what
it's just like oh well guess this
marriage isn't going through well marry
us and I'm like what universe you're the
priest they fit into everyone that
you've done pretty much everything not
to qualify for a cab that bit yeah that
priest is gonna be like I think you guys
need to talk this out first what the
fuck is this I'm Oprah don't you shut
the fuck up
oh that was the whole movie the whole
movie just to me can be summed up in
shut the fuck you know and it's not a a
chick flick saying it's not a you know I
my wife likes chick flicks and I have
watched some decent chick flicks
ridiculous chick flicks over-the-top bad
and this is the worst I've ever seen
hands down the worst I have ever seen I
thought I think there's something to
when like it's kind of a good feeling
when I brought up at like you know
princess what was it princess variety as
a chick flick and some people no it's
not no no it's actually
it's like it only is it's good but it
it's called The Princess Bride chick
flick you know but it's there's a sense
like going camping on a camping course
again there is nothing wrong with that
it can be a chip like an Inc ahead sign
handsome girls might like a dick like
old they might like transformers they
might like The Expendables ooh like you
know Expendables isn't it like it's an
addiction yeah I mean who the fuck are
you kidding but it's fine if you if you
like that stuff there's nothing wrong
with it nobody's gonna look at you like
oh well something's wrong with you
you're sincere and your gender is like
no it's fine these aren't that part of
me John I just thought it was insulting
to women everywhere cuz I'm like I'm
sorry older women have personalities you
can do a movie where they're not all
like Jared slay it God you know and even
the younger characters like Joker is
total tart just like you did and I'm she
may be a totally fine person as an
actress and very smart intelligent but
the character she plays like you can
just tell there ain't nothing going on
if she's not a single things most she's
a rare combination of stupid and insane
yeah she she is the girl that on your
first date the red flags go off left
Ryan like if if I were marrying some
girls like I decided to invite all three
of my fathers and not tell my mother I
have that red flag red flag red flag
like I don't forget to talk well that is
kind of what happens that's kind of what
happens when she said she gets upset at
that and I'm like you're insane you're
out of your fucking mind now remember
shouting that I was like this girl is
not so and then they don't get married
which he's fine with he's like oh I love
you well why aren't you getting married
then but B even if not you would not
take that as easily why didn't you
fucking say something if this was like
been chosen whatever two things one he's
insane because he just sat here going
through all of this marriage crap and
then all sounds like that's a canary or
two he didn't want to get married to
begin with
it was not good no anyway if I were a
girl I'd be like you took that way to my
if I were the guy and knowing how crazy
she is I would have been sitting over
thinking is this a test no I really want
to get married uh it's like yeah I who
knows what's going on in her mind you
know and then this and then the other
thing is a movie set in beautiful Greece
I mean the scenery is gorgeous starring
that a single fucking Greek nine anybody
who looks remotely the dude is about the
closest thing to look in Greek as you
get even the extras don't look that
Greek kind of a Senate movie in Greece
and it stars all these stupid white
people yeah like a once while that just
come in as like you know background
chorus like that's it that's all the
great piece I will say this it was great
for tourism because if anything at least
it made me really want to go take a trip
to Greece just so I could hug every
Greek I find and personally apologize
for Mamma Mia
I'm so sorry on behalf of America I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry so so please forgive
us
yeah you know what it uh you know the
the two comparisons we made when
watching the film one was that which I
put in the review was that it's a it's
kind of like a Six Flags show that they
put out for the little kids to keep you
know just a brainwave Eiland for the
over-40 female crew yeah uh but the
other thing I said too is that I don't
think I said I think this movie exists
for like you know women too like this or
middle-aged women to talk over like
always and everywhere oh oh so you know
I love this are the first time you heard
that song yet it like you're not
supposed to actually listen to this is
the movie that you're whatever
quote-unquote girlfriends put on when
they're just like hey like let's just
make a bunch of cocktails and just like
talk about shit and it's like oh let's
put on a movie women Mamma Mia
oh that peed on whatever like I'm a
grown-up let's just
you know and then occasionally it looks
nice and we land nothing and then this
is the movie that I think they look at
occasionally and they're just like what
the hell is going on yeah you're hey
check out that guy's bod and is like
that is saying no she can't she can't no
she can't
what is going on here is that Pierce
Brosnan's ready yeah like that is the
only thing I could figure that you would
get added Oh Oh God just really watching
the review with him because I preview
the reviews before they go up on
Tuesdays 5 minutes into it when the song
started it literally I a PTSD I like
started shaking and I was turned off for
a second done just just turn it off I
need a minute I need a minute it was
like an Amish parent watching Jeff I was
there were some like American sniper
shit going on with he threw that on ah
oh so in terms of did we uh was that
really what we thought of the movie uh
no apparently there was even more anger
that could have gotten out from it uh I
saw his review and I was like you were
way too ki yeah like I definitely don't
like it I like I dislike a lot more
films more than this but you know I'm
real I'll be honest I'm sure there are
worse things out there but as I said it
was tailor-made to annoying me and me
only like maybe there are others out
there who are as just as annoyed as I am
but of all the movies I've seen there
was something about every single thing
in this movie that just got on my
fucking nerves you know what I really
think that's like um that's like me a
Moulin Rouge which I really do hate
Moulin Rouge but it's like well I know
there's worse films it's a good-looking
film and all this stuff but it's like
there it just seems like there's some
sort of magic formula in there it's like
I just gonna really I'm just gonna do
this to you and this is gonna be the
most seen oh no we're to your hair or
not all your ear or something no no you
you want to know you want to know what
Mamma Mia was to me here you're just
hold very still
oh here oh wait give me a pen ah that's
mama Mia
that is what mama mia was to me fuck
so don't think we have much else on top
of that hate this movie um yeah I can't
think of too much else this is mostly
just a rant but that's by the fun um so
yeah if there's any other movies you
want to see uh some talk for realz about
or why no more why not as well as yeah
I'm gonna need like blood pressure
medicine or cell but there's definitely
ones like I'll get really upset about it
that there's still films don't give us
nice and angry uh or ones that like you
know like hook we like hook you know I
actually like for viewing you know so on
Jurassic Park it's a yeah so uh any
movie you want to see that we've
reviewed that like you want you want to
know more are real thoughts about it and
go into more detail uh yeah just leave
in the comments below we'll see we can
do it so uh see you next time
take care I'm sorry about your ear it's
okay no it's not